le glaucome est l'ennemi numéro un près
de 250 millions de personnes en
souffrent à travers le monde
ça représente 3 points 5 % des gens de
40 à 80 ans plus de 10 % des gens ou de
80 ans si la première cause de perte de
vision irréversible dans le monde
cet immense le glaucome est une pression
généralement élevée dans l'oeil qui
causent des dommages ou nerf optique le
nerf optique c'est comme le petit fils
électriques qui amène l'information de
l'oeil vers le cerveau ici le fil
électrique sans dommage le champ de
vision se resserre
comme dans un étau imaginez vous que
vous avez la plus belle télé du monde
les plus bleu des bleus les plus blanc
des blancs mais si on coupe le fil
électrique
la télé c'est un et le champ de vision
se rétrécit comment on traite le glauque
on en baissant la pression soit avec des
gouttes des lasers ou de la chirurgie je
m'appelle georges dur je suis médecin
ophtalmologiste spécialiste anglais
comme au chum et à l'université de
montréal
je me rappelle la première fois que j'ai
vu un implant de mme x men nguyen v6
quoi comme sur wii chirurgie
minimalement invasive de glaucome dans
une conférence étudiants en médecine et
je voyais ce magicien de l'oeil
implanté le plus petit stand du corps
humain dans le dre naturel jeu
d'émerveiller à travers ma résidence
j'ai traité toutes sortes de différentes
pathologies de l'oeil
j'ai appris à opérer plein de conditions
différentes
mais le traitement énigmatique de
glaucome ne t'ai toujours dans la tête
alors j'ai décidé de faire une fête au
chip non pas comme dans le seigneur des
anneaux une surspécialisation de deux en
anglais comme avec le gandalf de
l'ophtalmologie des mix
et quand m c'est lui qui m'a donné la
piqûre
quand je parle de mills je suis sûr que
vous pensez aux avions de chasse mais
non c'est tout aussi puissant par compte
regardez certaines énigmes ressemblent à
des avions d'autres à des petits
bouchons des petites paille les petits
cl d'ailleurs il ne mesure que 8 mm la
terre d'un style c'est un plan là alors
dans le fond moi je suis le plombier de
l'oeil
je m'occupe des drains comme je vais
parler plutôt les pressions élevées font
en sorte que le drain pas très
fonctionnel le dre en fait c'est une
petite veine qui fait le tour de l'oeil
qui étape à tapisser par une petit
filtre qui est généralement la zone
lorsque la résistance est la plus élevée
alors ce qu'on peut faire c'est dilater
cette veine là avec certains des
implants ou l'outrepasser complètement
en outrepassant on fait ce qu'on appelle
une bulle de filtration c'est une bulle
de liquide de l'oeil qui draine sous la
conjonctive la petite peau par dessus la
partie blanche de leurs hélas claire et
cette bulle de filtration par la suite
elle se draine dans leurs beats alors
avec nos mecs on donne des coups aux
méchants glaucome notre armée se
multiplient de plus en plus de maisons
disponibles et on a de plus en plus
d'armes à se battre contre le méchant
glaucome le méchant seront la chirurgie
de mix rentre maintenant dans un
algorithme de traitement
traditionnellement on avait les gouttes
les lasers éventuellement la chirurgie
les chirurgies de traditionnels font des
petits volets de la sq l'air la petite
partie blanche de l'oeil et permettent
aux liquides de drainer dans leur
ou bien on peut utiliser des tubes plus
large pour aller drainé dans leurs beats
les chirurgie traditionnelle fonctionne
et parfois elles sont nécessaires pour
les glo compte plus avancée mais parfois
elles fonctionnent trop la pression est
trop basse
on est victime de notre succès et il
donne des risques à long terme
d'infection alors qu'en est il des
glaucomes plus léger les glaucomes plus
stable c'est là le rôle des migs ça
donne des armes de plus pour se battre à
différents niveaux de maladie le
glaucome maintenant est devenu un
glaucome plus interventionnelle on veut
opérer plus tôt pour avoir des pressions
plus basse mais surtout de manière plus
sécuritaire terre au moment de la
chirurgie cataractes c'est un moment
opportun pour pouvoir mettre des mix la
cataracte
comme vous savez peut-être c'est la
pacification de la lentille naturel de
l'oeil
c'est comme si on voyait à travers d'un
voile alors lorsqu'on fait des trous
pour repris la cataracte en fait des
petites incisions un ou deux millimètres
c'est un moment idéal pour pouvoir
implanter les lumix dans le canal de
drainage d'ailleurs une des mères études
qu'on a dans le domaine dans les mx a
montré que l'implant did russe diminué
de 3 fois la nécessité d'avoir plus de
chirurgies de glaucome à 5 ans
comparativement à la charge et de
cataracte seuls trois fois moins de
risque de nécessiter une chirurgie plus
tard ça d'impact majeur sur nos passions
et si nous revenons à nos gouttes ans y
est vous que les gouttes était sans
conséquence
ça donne des yeux secs des yeux rouges
des unités ça rend les yeux plus creux
ça allonge les cils ça et certaines
personnes qui vont aimer ça
les gouttes et nous les faut surtout en
début de maladie
c'est bon pour contrôler puis c'est
souvent bien toléré par contre quand les
rangers de voir un astier 2 3 4 5
gouttes par jour ça commence à être plus
difficile pour les patients et on le
sait selon certaines études que jusqu'à
50% des gouttes ne sont pas mises comme
prescrits
donc toute personne qui va pour une
chirurgie 4 ac qui a du glaucome et qui
met des gouttes devrait avoir
l'opportunité de bain c'est son nombre
de gouttes pour améliorer sa qualité de
vie et son risque plus tard de nécessité
des chirurgies avant on regardait le
monde se détériorer avec leur glaucome
on attendait très très tard avant
d'offrir des chirurgies au patient mais
les mecs c'est des joueurs polyvalents
ils peuvent jouer plusieurs positions
pour les utiliser en début de maladie ou
plus tard celle avantages de ces
nouveaux outils connus et dans le futur
pas trop lointain
on va avoir des implants qui vont
contenir des médicaments ou des
thérapies géniques ciblées pour chaque
patient de plus en plus on a des
traitements adaptable c'était un domaine
effervescent et quand on parle des migs
les mines et moyens devaient se voir
comme surgies chirurgie minimalement
invasif de glaucome on parle
d'investissements dans les milliards
ces petits implants de quelques
millimètres ont des investissements dans
les milliards
avec notre âme et notre armée qui se
multiplient de plus en plus de
spécialistes de glaucome adhère au mix
notre algorithme de traitement a changé
les plus récalcitrants aux traitements
sont rendus des fervents partisans des
mix je veux finir par vous parler de
madame m qui avait un glaucome avancée
des champs de vision qui ce retrait si
c'est comme dans un étau elle mettait
beaucoup de gouttes qu'elle ne tolérait
pas bien les lasers fonctionnait pas
très bien non plus il ya un an on a
décidé de lui faire des mixes et depuis
ces pressions sont contrôlés ses yeux
sont confortables sa vision s'est
stabilisée elle est heureuse et
optimiste de pouvoir vivre avec sa
vision pour le reste de ses jours
f
[Applaudissements]